ok
well
the character
though
and
[Music]
walking gloria ortiz and the art
art
pockets
and maybe I turned them around
we've been there for 14 years
and
she's a very active girl she
's very serious she likes a lot of books
when she gets to
believe doing  something she is very
disciplined and if not
i
has not been in
a public one
because she liked it it has been an easy
problem but it limits problems but
children's
things that sometimes they struggle with some things and
we as parents want to help and
sometimes  instead of helping we do things we
don't help them the same because our
education was different
why is it a school
for other girls I like that they are going
to teach them how to become leaders it is something that
we need right now in these times we
need more girls being
professionals and knowing  what do you
want
to change this position
now we received a call
my wife was the one who received the call
I happened to be there
I said let's see let's  find out
we are going to see how to see is something that interests us
when we arrived not long ago the
attention to others
[Music]
why
that logic does not seem
the battery of drugs
the education that they are going to receive the one who is
going to exercise tomorrow is something
very  important because when you get
up you
need something that your
blood starts to flow for what
do I understand more things and secondly what I already
mentioned that leadership is
very good no well
I like it
because boys are a little more restless
and girls pay more attention  they are a little
more mature at that age
of consumption
yes right now I haven't met all of them
but yes
at first
[Music]
forgive
my mind
to some of them not all the
manifest ones
I don't think that the 6 of the
children safe is what  main and they are good things
as was the other question
moveman and in this way decorated
the security of putting
I think that yes it is good it is more it is
safer because the teacher if all
the people all the per  sonal is going to
meet the children
in that in that matter they if a
child comes out or something they will all be there they will
meet the girls
m
already with the cruises
[Music] they
will arrive if you want in my life
d
I am four who come like this
but changing
why
air
[Music]
d
the berliner
and then
[Music]
up to an
efe
40 unit
for example
from now on
and yes
because it is not going to be applied
[Music]
go
they take charge web
[Music]
there are members who have labels there
urban ministers and not
[Music]
well
although when we learned about this school
we realized that we can be the
first generation of this school it is
very nice to know that and that my daughter
feels interested in it and above all
that we see that we are so close to me in
the place where we can train our
sons and our daughters from now on so that
they can open their minds and know that they
can go to the university here from
the megas
forming their future is our priority  ity
as parents that our children are trained
in this case our daughter
we only have a girl and we believe that in this
school they are here to help them without
distinction it is a way for them to
empower themselves and to know that they can do it
I love it above all that they are
bilingual  The founder is a totally humble person, she
speaks English and Spanish, something that I
feel totally identified with. We really
know the person who will be
managing it, who went to the director
of my daughter's elementary school, so
we know her and we are very happy to
meet the staff, we have been seeing it
through videos and we find it very
interesting that they are all very prepared
because it is absolutely very
flattering because the girls will not have
any distractions, they will be
focused, perhaps they will feel a
little competitive but that will
help them and it will  motivating precisely
the leadership area is something that
we are really looking for
her, which is her  a is a bit serious
but we know that it has the
perfect capacity to be able to enjoy
but because we
know that the safety and well
-being of all the children is a priority in the
school we know the plan that the
founder has the director we know that they are
going to  maintain a necessary distance they are
going to try to keep the children
with the necessary security that is
required with what they say
so that they are healthy first of
all they have the project they have
is very good that is they are going to have to be
in different  times but whatever it is
for them is fine this person is
good one of the main benefits
since we are precisely affiliated
or part of the camps de jour in the
beat and from here we are already
guiding our daughters and those are the
main benefits
to  part of the academic that they are already
focusing on going to school if
not here for somewhere else but that
they already have the bases p  In order
to be able to pursue a career that they
want,
well
and under construction
and they
will
spend their time, then she receives
the education,
something good for her, it
is a
good one, I like the idea that they
will receive an education,
they will pay attention  to each child in their
growth perhaps some will go
faster others will go slower but with
the help of the system of
the children's fields to be able to advance
as they can the rhythm of each
child is different we know but
some children  They can probably go
further ahead and that is the advantage that they
can go further ahead and they don't have to
wait and those who are a little further
back will help them to continue
and with the no of the other children